most major air pollutants cannot be seen
although large amounts of them
concentrated in cities are variable are
visible as smog
so this actually feels decent it's not
as cleanly written as i might like but
it doesn't seem like there's any
outright errors especially where they
underlined so of them well this is large
amounts of them well them is referring
to the major air pollutants so that this
is completely cool
large amounts of them concentrated in
cities well that that's they're saying
well these are the large amounts of the
air pollutants concentrated in cities
this is making grammatical sense
are visible so we're talking about
something that's plural so
it completely makes sense to use the
plural form of the verb so are visible
as smog so this makes complete
grammatical sense so i would say that
this has
no error